You should have changed the TextView
into a ListView element.
Then you can remove this text attribute
because you don't need it anymore.
Now from the UX Mocks, you'll remember
that the list takes up the whole screen,
so we want to set the width and height
to be match_parent.
That will make the ListView
match the dimensions of its parent,
which is this RelativeLayout.
And to find out the parent
of this RelativeLayout,
it's actually in this activity_main XML file
because the fragment
is contained within the activity.
Within this file, we see that this view
is also match_parent for height and width.
So now we can confirm that the ListView
actually will take up the full screen.
Going back to the fragment_main file,
we can add the id,
listview_forecast, onto the ListView.
And then, since this layout
only contains one child,
we can simplify the layout
by changing this into a FrameLayout.